these cameras take excellent still
photos they also take great
high-definition video you just have to
rethink how you use them with video the
camera needs to be kept horizontal never
vertical if you need to shoot something
tall you can't just turn the camera
instead try tilting up and back down to
capture the full image another big
difference between shooting Stills and
video is the autofocus autofocus doesn't
work when the subject is in motion since
video is all about capturing movement
it's better to use manual focus
there are several frames per second
options for a cinematic look pick 24
frames per second then set your shutter
speed at one fiftieth of a second
indoors or out you adjust the aperture
depending on the lighting before I start
shooting any video and make sure my
camera is at one fiftieth of a second I
adjust my aperture according to the
lighting my lens is on manual focus I
focus the scene and then I start
shooting my video
you